It's great to welcome to the program today,
Ben Burtt, this who's a philosophy professor
at Georgia state
university, a university perimeter college
and author of the book, give them an argument
logic for the left, which I'm very, very interested
to talk about. Ben, really great to have you
on.
Yeah, thanks for having me.
So before we get into like the material, you
and I have both appeared on the Jesse Lee
Peterson show and I've told my audience my,
I don't really take it super seriously. I
think it's sort of like an avant garde performance
art sort of thing. What, what was your approach
when you were invited? Like, I'm guessing
you were familiar with the types of interviews
he does?
Oh, actually I've got to say, I really was
not so, so his, uh, his producer contacted
me. He was a little bit vague about what this
was, but I was like, yeah, sure, whatever.
I'll do it. And then like I kind of looked
him up on Wikipedia as like, okay, this is
going to be a hostile interview. You know,
kind of got a sense of what the guy's views
were. Yeah. But you know, whatever I'm game,
I've done that. Uh, and then, uh, I mean I
think it was probably much funnier because
I really didn't know what I was getting into.
Um, but um, you know, but whatever, like,
you know, like I said, it's, it's not the
most, it's not the most serious thing and
you know, and I think it makes for some good
clips.
Yeah. I mean, so it kind of leads into what
I want to talk with you about because in the
book and in general, you talked about the
way that the left can and should use logic
and reasoning and this is very prevalent in
online discussions where also the format of
the discussion can be very limiting in terms
of, you know, what, what the strategies are
that can be employed successfully. What is,
I mean you can't, like if you go to Jesse
Lee Peterson and try to just do logic and
say, hold the, you know, like I do, hold on
Jesse, you're saying, Hey, now you're saying
the opposite of a, I don't even know what
your position is. You're misstating my position.
It's sort of like a black hole of logic, so
to speak. So do you think that a lot of the
ideas of how the left should debate are context
dependent?
Oh, absolutely. Yeah. I mean, something that
I do try to emphasize a few times in the book
is that I'm not recommending that anybody
give an unlimited amount of their time and
energy to like anybody who wants to argue
about anything ever. Uh, I think that you
need to be selective and strategic about it.
And I'm not sure that there is a good way,
for example, to, uh, to go on the Jesse Lee
Peterson show at least if your goals are anything
except for to, you know, have kind of like,
you know, something that like will, you know,
people find amusing later when they watch
it. Uh, you know, so I think that the reasons
that are, that it's important to be better
at reasoning, uh, and to, and to make more
explicit arguments for left positions and
to like spend more time taking apart, you
know, bad right-wing arguments, uh, don't
necessarily translate it to say that you should
like engage with any particular forum in which
the opportunity to, uh, to do that do that
arises. Because, you know, obviously, you
know, if, if somebody, you know, if you have
somebody who just wants to ask you loaded
questions and then yell at you for not giving
a yes or no answers, uh, you know, there is
no amount of, of like showing why he's using
bad reasoning that's going to make much of
a dent in that situation.
Is there any particular area of focus in terms
of topics where you see that the left is not
arguing in what you would identify as the
most logically, um, a well-reasoned and effective
way, whether it's a particular social issue
or GOP. I mean just anything is w like where,
what would be exhibit a in your mind of where
we should be looking to what not to do?
Yeah, sure. So, uh, so I think, uh, that one
thing that, uh, that we do a lot of that we
should, you know, that we should not do is
just kind of generally speaking when encountering,
you know, conservative or libertarian arguments,
uh, kind of, you know, making fun of them
and then leaving it at that, right. You know,
that they have that, uh, just sort of doing
the mockery but not actually ever explained.
Getting around to explaining what's wrong
with the argument, which is a bad move, not
just, um, for some like, high-minded reason
of principle, but because it gives me, it
gives fence sitters the understandable impression
that you don't really have a good response
to the argument. Uh, and so I guess, uh, one,
uh, one small example is, uh, when people
are talking about, um, about trans rights
and, you know, and uh, and, uh, affirming,
you know, gender identities of trans people.
Uh, very often I see people using a pretty
bad argument for that, which is to sort of
try to deny that there is an underlying distinction
about biological sex. I don't think that's
a good move because I think that, you know,
in any other context we would cry quite rightly
say that the mere fact that like there are,
there are ambiguous cases between two categories
doesn't mean that there's no real underlined
distinction between the categories. I think
a much better way of arguing for the same
conclusions as far as rights and dignity for
trans people and calling people whatever pronouns
they want to be called as a matter of basic
human decency is to say that there are multiple
ways of using words like man and woman and
sure one of them might track biological sex
and other might track, um, you know, gender
identity and gender expression and that it's
a matter of basic human decency. They use
the ladder and you know, most contexts.
Yeah. I feel like it's interesting you bring
that one up because I as someone obviously
staunchly on the left who wants to, um, uh,
do everything. I can to support just treating
everybody decently and making sure that under
the law people aren't, you know, all of the
stuff that would fall under that. I feel that
I tread carefully when I even want to talk
about how we're talking about that issue because
rightly or wrongly I worry that if I say the
wrong thing I'm going to trigger a backlash
where the black backlash itself becomes the
focus, which is not at all my goal, if that
makes sense.
Yeah, absolutely.
Uh, w let's talk a little bit about when it
comes to I F I've talked before about how
I think on some issues the right has a sort
of structural advantage that aligns with their
positions politically. And I'll give two examples
to get your thoughts on it. One is abortion,
the other is taxation. The right has a structural
advantage when talking about abortion for
example, because their position is so simple
and cut and dry that the left can't possibly
oppose it with something as pithy and concise,
which is abortion is murder and therefore
that it is wrong period. And of course the
position on the left is not the opposite of
that. It's not is great and let's have more
of them. It's a nuanced position on taxation.
On one position on the right is it's my money,
I earned it. I shouldn't get to keep as much
of it as whatever. And then they will usually
draw the line. And of course the position
on the left is not the opposite of no, the
government should get all your money. It's
a new one's position that requires understanding
what are we trying to fund, what is our responsibility
to society? Do you see that as a structural
advantage for the right is question one and
question two is what can we on the left have
as a tool to counteract it?
Yeah. So I think that that definitely gives
them an advantage. Uh, certainly when you're
pushing back against those things, we can't
push back against them by saying, you know,
that, uh, you know, we think it'd be fine
if the taxation rate for middle income people
was 100%, uh, or that, you know, be fine to
have an abortion, you know, five minutes before
a the delivery day, you know, um, would've
happened anyway. Uh, but, um, we have to,
you know, we have to impose some nuance there.
In fact, actually, ironically, I think in
the abortion case, the right is making the
same mistake that well-intentioned people
on the left off and making the case I just
described, which is to say, well, all right,
you have two categories. Uh, it's ambiguous
when you go from one to the other because
you know, you have a sort of series of stages
where you're slowly approaching, uh, the distinction
and it's not clear where the sharp cutoff
point is, right? Where you go from a mindless
collection of cells, uh, to something that
should clearly have whatever moral rights
a human baby has a therefore, because we're
not sure where the cutoff point is there,
you know, there just isn't a real distinction
or you know, it must be the same thing all
along, which is the continuum fallacy, which
is again the mistake I think some of us are
making in other contexts.
You, so I've talked at one way I fight against
the continuum fallacy is by saying, listen,
if you set a speed limit of 35 miles per hour,
you're not saying 37 is always unsafe. And
you're not saying that sometimes if the conditions
are poor, you don't have to go much slower.
The fact that one line doesn't apply exactly
in all cases doesn't mean we don't have to
set the line somewhere as a society. I've
been trying to use some version of that. But
can you, can you talk about where else the
left is incorrectly relying on the continuum
fallacy? Cause that's interesting to me.
Yeah. Uh, so, uh, there's sort of arguments
that deny biological sex I think are the most
obvious examples of the left doing it. I think,
uh, it's certainly easy to come up with examples
where I think the writer is guilty of this.
The abortion as the example is one of them.
Uh, another one is the response that a lot
of people had to, um, Rashida to leave when
she said that. Um, well, OK, uh, the minimum
wage when, you know, the sort of fight for
15 movement started in like 2012, $15 made
sense. But now, uh, especially given how long
it would take to get any of this legislation
fully into place, the reasonable range would
be more like 18 to 20. And a lot of right
wingers jumped on that and they're like, Oh,
well 20, why not 25, one at 50. Why not $1,000
an hour?
And like the speed limit case, you can say,
well, hold on just because there's some ambiguity,
right? Just because, okay. Eighteens probably
fine. 19, there's 20 is probably fine. That
doesn't mean that, you know, at, it's a little
unclear when you cross the line to what would
be unreasonable and unworkable. That doesn't
mean that there isn't a real distinction there
that $1,000 would be fine, right? If we changed
the speed limit to 36 miles an hour, that
would probably be fine. Uh, but obviously
that's different from, you know, just have
it in auto bond where you can go as fast as
you want or you don't have it. The speed limit
be a hundred miles an hour, which would be
incredibly dangerous. So, uh, so yeah, and
I think that you could also just use the sort
of common sense example. Start with somebody
who's completely bald, add a hair to their
head at a hair, at a hair until they're like
Fabio, at some point they stopped being bald.
We can't tell exactly when that is, but it's
obviously a logical mistake to say, therefore
they're just used to distinction between being
bald and being not bold.
Well, this gets to maybe one of the most interesting,
um, uh, broader questions around argumentation
that I have with politics, which is that I've
been critical in some ways of the movements
that are all about establishing their set
of principles and guidelines and in a vacuum
staking out what their ideology is. Because
I think that there's two risks to that. One
risk is you definitely, when arguing, run
the risk of getting pulled into what I call
these philosophical black holes that ultimately
solve no real problems. And more importantly,
I think the difficult work is in actually
figuring out what balance of our principles
should be applied in the real world to solve
problems we're facing. And I think that sometimes
the, the overwhelming focus merely on abstract
principles actually prevents us from solving
real world issues. Do you think that that
is a concern and how do you balance that between
that and pragmatics?
Yeah. Well. So I think this is actually one
of the important themes of the book, which
is the, um, when we talk about like kind of
taking logic and you know, back to the left
from the sort of, um, you know, right-wing
libertarian types who like love to go on and
on about how they love fat logic, facts and
reason kind of use these phrases, almost like
magical incantations, you know, that means
two things. One of them is, you know, making
better, again, I'll show showing what's wrong
with those people's arguments and make it
arguments for better positions. But the other
one, which is even more important is taken
back the sort of way that we're going about
it from them. Right? So one thing that's incredibly
damaging about these guys is that they've
convinced so many people that carried about
logic and reasoning. It means like having
like three, like first principles and just
extrapolate in everything from that.
But of course, uh, that's not good reasoning.
Right. You know, like you have to take it
all sorts of other things into account. You
know, if you start with the first principle,
then you run into problems, you should go
back to the drawing board and see if your
principle isn't great. Uh, and so I get, I
think a lot of this does take new ones. I
think I get what you're saying about pragmatics
that, you know, it could be that, you know,
if we're just, you know, doing nuance nuance
nuance all the time, then you know, you're
sort of gonna lose the political war of the
people who have simple easily understood ideas.
Uh, and so I think there's a balance there
between, on the one hand showing that we can,
uh, make, you know, good nuanced critiques
of those people's ideas, which for anybody
who just, you know, might think that we don't
have a good answer or might be sort of taken
in by those ideas who's like intellectually
sincere that might help them.
But at the same time, we can put forward counter
narratives that aren't just necessarily nuance
nuance nuance all the time. Like, you know,
we care, you know, like a right to abortion
is important because people should have a
right to control their own bodies. You know,
a recently like redistributive taxation is
good, you know, because a fair society is,
you know, is more equal and really meaningfully
more free for most people. And you know, we
can kind of put forward those counter narratives
without falling into being totally simplistic
about the, and saying that like, um, you know,
well, the right to bodily autonomy is so important
that you know, that if you are gonna give
birth on Tuesday, you can have an abortion
on Monday. Right? We don't have to, you know,
we don't have to sort of stick to our guns,
uh, like a libertarian who's argued with themselves
to the point of like, denying the age of consent
laws. Uh, but we could still, we could still
put forward reasonable, uh, clearly understood
principles
in a sense. We need to have a variety of tools
at our disposal and know in what proportion
different tools should be applied to particular
jobs, I guess is the way that I would, uh,
sort sort of sum it up. And a lot of these
tools are in Ben's book. Give them an argument.
Logic for the left. Ben Burgess is a philosophy
professor at Georgia state university, perimeter
college. I, I think I did a better job saying
all the words [inaudible]
that time. Ben, I really appreciate your time
and it's been so great having you on. Thank
you so much.